[Musique]
après deux ans de pandémie mondiale
j'avais besoin de mes 21 besoin de
quitter mon orbite pour découvrir un
sujet loin de ma réalité l'alimentation
dans l'espace
pour en parler david saint-jacques
astronaute canadien qui a passé plus de
deux cent quatre jours
vous rappelez vous la première bouchée
vous avez pris dans l'espace que ce que
ça caille probablement un café en fait
allemand un café en regardant à faire
bienvenue dans la cuisine l'aca spatiale
qu'est ce qu'on mange quand on part pour
un voyage 139 millions de kilomètres
qu'est ce qu'on mange il ya peut-être
une centaine de menu disponible sur une
rotation le passé plusieurs mois en
france a mangé la même chose de poids si
tu veux puisque pascal malfoy ne sais
quel chacune des agences spatiales
participants amène sa propre nourriture
fait qu'on peut se tromper changé
qu'est ce qui est possible de manger
dans l'espace des choses vraiment à
challans a mangé un espace c'est par
exemple les arachides télé petit peu
l'urne
alors tout ce qui est peut créer de la
petite poudre ou des petits flocons ça
c'est à proscrire parce que sa flotte et
puis ça rend des yeux
qui reçoit par exemple
passer la marche
sur cette question je fais plus
confiance à l'astronaute ko même si
c'est pour mettre du sel et du poivre
cette populace appartient aux yeux donc
on a sur lui c'est un excellent liquide
comme ça
on a aussi du poivre liquide est ce que
je remarque c'est que vous avez ce
groupe il soit trop de poids une
bouteille de cirage grosse comme ça
c'est celle de loin la plus populaire ou
mais le cirad chaud ça vient de temps en
temps le sait les promène régulièrement
ces mêmes personnel c'est comme notre
parti de ton quête personnelle
les épices et assaisonnements sont
d'autant plus importants que le goût et
alter irna présentant une paire de dés
gens un espace et un peu congestionné se
sent pas grand chose il ya pas de
gravité pour attirer les foules vers les
jambes donc le sentiment d'avoir le
rhume le nez bouché tout le temps c'est
surtout pire dans le premier mois après
et encore après le très léger ça puisse
arriver normal la plupart des repas sont
emballés dans des boîtes de conserve ou
dix sachets métallique et ils sont aussi
souvent lyophilisés il faut que ce soit
chose qui vient pas de récit de la
tablette pendant un an ou deux c'est un
peu sur le seul critère cydia phillies
et on rajoute de l'eau chaude une
machine sur le mur quantité à
température bout voilà je suis la
recette on brasse un peu on laisse
reposer une dernière
c'est ainsi que david saint-jacques a pu
déguster dans la station spatiale le
chili comme caribou préparé par sa
conjointe sur est bonne
mais réussit le tour de force envoyé
dans l'espace
la nourriture maison une recette
familiale de chilly d'expédition on
passe du premier à avoir ce privilège
à bord donc il ya une partie de la
nouvelle équipe qui vient avec vous puis
une autre partie de nourriture vous
prenez votre cellulaire vous appelez you
were space s'est livré dans l'espace et
on me dit que vous êtes un expert du
canada pour attraper les vaisseaux car
exactement oui si vous de l'échappée
vous mangez pas pendant un mois qu'est
ce qui se passe en fait on garde
toujours à boire au moins six mois de
nourriture dans la rue ok donc on la
consomme t ball cargo pour rappeler le 6
mois
prochaine étape dans l'exploration
spatiale démission de plusieurs années
vers la lune et aussi vers mars et elle
se rêve de faire de la confiture sur
mars un jour est déjà ça travaille fort
sur terre pour trouver des façons de
produire des aliments dans l'espace
comme ce concours piloté par la nasa et
l'agencé spatiale canadienne le défi de
l'alimentation dans l'espace lointain
quand on parle de l'image j'imagine que
c'est surtout des végétaux contente de
faire croître dans l'espace
certains projets finalistes vienne
d'universités québécoises
des criquets ont
pu imaginer seulement des faibles
pourcentages de nourriture qui sera
produite sur place ça sera plus un
terrain d'expérimentation
dans le futur des années on espère
pouvoir augmenter ce pourcentage avoir
plus de nourriture fraîche qui est
produite sur place
toute cette recherche aura aussi des
répercussions pour des communautés sur
terre tout ce qu'on peut développer pour
un délai à s'entassent nourrir vers mars
un peu de folie
c'est évidemment des choses qui vont
servir demain matin la ligne 8 c'est ce
concept on était capable de faire
pousser la nourriture sur place à
l'univers d'un article montre également
de faire passer sur mars s'est pas
beaucoup plus compliqué avant de mettre
fin à cette entrevue j'avais une
dernière question pour notre astronautes
avec votre plus grand bonheur dans
l'espace à manger cet accord fois par
semaine et un droit à une heure ou deux
le vidéo chat et donc que le dimanche
matin j'avais la joie de déjeuner avec
mes enfants
j'avais trouvé des gaufres déshydraté et
j'avais du sirop d'érable donc aussi sur
des gaufres ou sur dab manger la même
chose qu'eux
parmi mes meilleurs souvenirs et
nourriture ces déjeuners comme ça avec
eux
[Musique]